hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und wundert euch nicht warum ich hier
gerade eine dusche stehe ich habe ein
video für den management aufgenommen
das seht ihr dann bald auf seinem kanal
also verpasst nicht ihn zu abonnieren
und mal vorbeizuschauen
was ich euch endlich erzählen möchte ist
dass ich wieder mit einem video um die
ecke komme von meiner sendung
fantastisch und zwar habe ich ein video
über plastik gemacht da ist so ein
wichtiges thema ist wollte ich das auch
unbedingt hier hochladen weil mir das
echt nahe geht und ich gerade selber
versuche mich dahingehend zu verändern
dass ich umweltfreundlicher und
bewusster über die umwelt nachdenke und
jetzt würde ich sagen
viel spaß bei den video und save the
nature
heute geht es um müll um genau zu sein
um plastikmüll den wir täglich in die
tonne werfen viele gedanken habt ihr
euch schon über plastikmüll gemacht für
mich könnte das immer zum leben dazu
sowie das essen mit dieser einstellung
bin ich bestimmt nicht allein gewesen
doch zu denken dass klassik müll da ist
und man nichts dagegen tun kann ist
einfach falsch und um mehr über
plastikmüll zu erfahren habe ich einen
gast eingeladen glas wie die lustige
plastiktüte hallo kinder
hallo hallo klasse klasse i sag mal ich
habe ein paar fragen zum thema plastik
und ich habe gehört dass du uns sie
beantworten kannst na dann tschüss mal
los wo finden wir denn überall plastik
plastik finden wir überall supermärkten
zur verpackung von lebensmitteln und in
den einkaufstüten die wir mit nach hause
nehmen
ich hatte trotzdem ein paar fragen zu
diesem thema und haben den großen weiten
des internets nach antworten gesucht was
wir unter den plastikmüll verstehen ist
wahrscheinlich jedem bekannt was für
mich aber neu war
jährlich werden 200 bis 250 millionen
tonnen plastik hergestellt
250 millionen tonnen warum wird so viel
plastik hergestellt plastik wird an
vielen orten eingesetzt in der industrie
in
elektronik aber auch in kosmetikartikeln
findet man plastik so genanntes micro
plastik das ist in peelings drin in
krems ja wir schmieren uns das auch ins
gesicht dieses micro plastik ist so
winzig dass es durch unser abflüsse in
die kläranlagen gerät und diese das
nicht herausfiltern könnt browser ist so
winzig ist und so gelangt es direkt ins
meer was uns zu unserer nächsten frage
führt was sind die auswirkungen von
unserem plastik waren so wie ich es
heraus lesen konnte sind unsere meere
und ozeane am schlimmsten davon
betroffen nicht nur dass das mikro
plastik ins wasser gelangt in die fische
und somit wieder in unsere nahrungskette
nein schiffe laden auch ihren müll im
wasser ab manchmal aus versehen und
manchmal und ganz oft mit absicht aber
auch nun müll den wir auf den straßen
liegen lassen ist eine belastung für die
umwelt verdrossen sich an den
plastikteilen oder fressen ist und
sterben dadurch denn je magen vermittelt
ihnen das hier sind und dass sie voll
sind und daran verhungern sie dann
einfach ist das nicht toll
ich meine wir machen uns ein paar netten
schon genug kaputt und man kann nicht
alles von jetzt auf gleich perfekt
umsetzen dass es mir klar nur man muss
es einfach versuchen was uns schon zu
unserem nächsten frage führt was kann
ich dagegen tun
einige supermärkte gehen schon mit einem
guten beispiel voran und verzichten
komplett auf plastiktüten und auch beim
shoppen kann man auf plastiktüten
verzichten in dem man sich einfach
taschen selbst mitbringen meine arme
machen wieder party bestimmt hat jeder
von euch ein beutel oder eine tasche zu
hause die man zum einkaufen verwenden
kann kommen wir noch mal zu meinem
lieblingsthema micro plastik um zu
verhindern dass dieses micro plastik in
die abflüsse gelangt informieren sich im
internet darüber welche produkte plastik
enthalten und welche nicht da könnt ihr
dann zum beispiel polyethylen
polypropylen
politiker hat da kann ganz komische
dinge drin sein bis wir auf der
rückseite sieht man sie aber hin zu
kleiden also zutaten kommen wir aber zu
verpackungen und lebensmittel mandarin
und avocados in plastikbehältern wir
nehmen die schutzhülle der natur und
ersetzen sie durch plastik selbst gucken
werden eingeschweißt die haben ja nicht
ohne grund ihre schale und was können
wir dagegen tun
wir können die lebensmittel schon im
supermarkt auspacken und sie dort in den
mülleimer schmeißen der supermarkt ist
verpflichtet unseren müll anzunehmen und
ihm kostenpflichtig zu entsorgen das
heißt irgendwann müssen sie einsehen
dass das mir diesen verpackungen keinen
sinn macht und einfach für sie zu teuer
ist es gibt sogar lebensmittelgeschäfte
die komplett auf verpackung verzichten
in berlin haben wir zum beispiel den
laden original und verpackt bei dem du
dann deine beutel und ein glas selbst
mit drinks und die sachen darin ab
füllst und es ist alles da müsli mehl
reis gemüse eier obst alles kann zu lack
auf und verpackt natürlich kann man
nicht von jetzt auf gleich komplett auf
verpackungen bei lebensmitteln
verzichten aber man kann ist sicher
reduzieren und wenn ihr schon
plastiktüten zu hause liegen habt dann
schaut doch mal auf pinterits nach der
weiß mit den irrsee kreativ weiter
bewerten können und falls ihr wollt kann
ich auch mal was davon ausprobieren so
und die letzte frage die wir uns jetzt
heute noch stellen sollten ist dann
fange ich an
auf meine umwelt zu achten antwort ist
ganz simpel jetzt huwald tiefgründig zu
bieten
ich weiß plastik ist jetzt nicht gerade
das witzigste thema ich hoffe trotzdem
dass ich vielleicht ein paar von euch
erreichen konnte und wer weiß vielleicht
lassen wir die verpackung und zukunft
auch im supermarkt ich habe jetzt ein
paar mal schon gemacht und es ist
ziemlich cool muss ich sagen also meinem
gemüsefach sind nur unverpackte
paprikaschoten und was weiß ich alles
und das die ganze verpackung habe ich im
laden gelassen und es war ein gutes
gefühl demnächst werde ich auch mal zu
diesem original unverpackt laden gehen
und mir das mal anschauen wie das so ist
komplett unverpackte sachen zu kaufen am
sonntag kommt dann aber wieder auch ein
lustiges video und ich überlege ein
video über vegetarische ernährung zu
machen und nicht
also dieses standard ding sondern ganz
besonders auf wie kann ich fleisch
ersetzen also zum beispiel machen wir
uns ja immer noch spaghetti bolognese
oder essen burritos oder frittiertes
hühnchen gibt es ja alles in soja und so
da würde ich auch gern mal was darüber
erzählen wie krass man eigentlich
fleisch ersetzen kann ohne es zu
vermissen
ein schnitzel kann man immer noch essen
ihr könnt einfach mal in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr so ein vegetarisches
ernährungs schließlich tot video sehen
wollt dafür kommentiert ihr dann mit
eurer lieblings gemüsesorten für jahr
und mit eurem lieblings fleischgericht
mit nein
ich muss es aber auch langsam meine
sachen packen denn es geht diese woche
wohin wo ich nicht aber verraten